what characterizes a drone Film Festival
well drone film festival is well first
of all our film festival is the first
film festival exclusively dedicated to
drone cinema and a drone film is really
just one that's been shot with a drone
in our particular case it's fifty
percent or more shot with a drone and
all the entries have to be under five
minutes all right under five minutes
fifty percent or more of the content has
to be shot using these aerial unmanned
vehicles flying around with a camera
tell us about some of the features some
of the films that people could see in
the film festival I mean these
submissions were absolutely amazing when
I first started this I was totally
unsure about what the submissions would
be like would they be just somebody
picking up a DJI phantom and just flying
it for the first time or would they be
amazing works of art that people had
been creating with more expensive
professional rigs and the answer to that
was out of 150 submissions that were
that were submitted they were they
really kind of ran spectrum and they're
amazing it really are amazing now the
winners are going to be selected on
March the 7th are people going to be
able to view all of the videos all of
the films while the festival goes on can
they check it out online I mean you can
go around and scavenge and find the
various links here or there because
ultimately when people have shot them
over the past year they put them online
I mean essentially youtube and vimeo are
kind of the repositories for all peoples
drone films until we've created this
film festival then hopefully next year
they'll create them just for the film
festival itself tell us about some of
the sponsors that want to participate
with this i mean we have some of the
best sponsors in the world it's it's
pretty much Oprah's Favorite Things
worth of drone drones and drone
accessories and all kinds of various you
know kind of like all of our favorite
you know things I mean they're really
amazing what have you learned about
using drones as a method for
cinematography not just the artistic
part of it but there are human benefits
to this you know drones they get a bad
rap which is unfortunate because some of
the people that you know kind of
pooh-poohing them the most which is in
the media could really benefit from them
the most but there's tons of
humanitarian benefits disaster relief
they can they get really
interesting and amazing views on things
they can find missing people they're I
mean they're essentially it's a computer
with wings a computer with wings that
you have used that capture some images
of New York City how did you first get
interested in using drones and
cinematography together well I'm a
director and I'm always kind of looking
for new toys that are going to get me an
interesting perspective and I saw a shot
in a skateboard video and it just kind
of blew my mind I was I was wondering
how they could have possibly made this
shot happen it just went in in
directions that I've never seen before
and I just kept watching and watching
and I paused on one frame and I saw a
flying camera and I was like what is
this and I immediately got on the next
day and I started buying drones and
putting them together and then when I
made aerial NYC it went so viral I was
like you know what I should submit this
to a film festival and lo and behold
there were none so where can people see
Ariel NYC they can just if they google
it they can find it it it got amazing
coverage earlier in the year and but I
definitely do not recommend flying like
that that was years ago and I think now
it's it's a little too hot i think i
think people should be very careful when
they're flying drones especially in in
this kind of airspace